it's been a whirlwind big Welwyn yeah
yeah how are you I'm good I'm doing
great I am equally terrified and excited
of all the things that lay ahead of me
or possibly lay ahead of me and I am you
know currently adjusting to a a new fall
season what are you gonna do like what
do you have lined up for yourself there
is it's actually really exciting for me
there was a couple of projects that I
was a part of in the offseason that now
I can really focus on mold there's
actually two shows that I was a part of
one called the storm and one ester and
both are trying to get to Broadway in
the next couple of years and they are
just so wonderful and the fact that I'm
even asked to be their lead is an honor
and we did have showcase a first
showcase for both of them and they went
really really well
Esther is a beautiful story taken from
the Bible but very much about a female
empowerment this woman who becomes queen
loses herself in it a little bit and
then finds what to do with it and how to
create something positive and I think
it's such a story we want now and
something I resonate with I was gonna
say that reminds me of you guys it's our
serve resonate with that with you know
being a country girl that fell into
Hollywood and then had to figure that
out and now wants to do good with it so
that feels right for me and it's so
unique in its concept where I I'm
dancing and I'm acting through movement
but there are singers that are my voice
and it's all done through song and the
writing of the music is just phenomenal
it really hits you in the heartstrings
so that's Esther we are currently still
bringing all the funding so we can get
it to go to the next stage and it's
really beautiful and exciting and the
other one is the storm where I am
singing dancing and acting Oh
triple threat triple threat I made my
singing debut in July August this year
and that was wonderful and terrifying
but epic at the same time acting always
been on that bucket list for you oh god
yeah yeah I love acting I mean I'm a
storyteller yeah you see me even with
dance it's the things that I love to
create the most and I've been in acting
for quite a while now and that's the
other thing that I can really dive into
and commit to being in class and working
on projects and getting out to auditions
and really diving into the
part of my my passion now which is
really kind of epic famila so when one
door closes several doors so it then so
it seemed I got the really super sad
phone call that was a is this real life
moment for me I was driving on the
freeway on my way to a meeting and I was
chatting with our executive producer and
I could hear it the minute he got on the
phone and his voice I was like when was
this compared to when the announcement a
day or two before we were supposed to
start rehearsal Eve it was the Friday
but it may have been the Thursday it was
the same day that Adam got the phone
call within an hour of each other and we
were supposed to go into rehearsals for
GMA because I too was getting the texts
about be ready for this and the why not
I came back early from a retreat in
Sedona just to be made sure that I was
ready to do things and they got moved
but that happens when so up until this
point though you really thought I'm
gonna be on this season you're excited I
remember you told me I'm going for
back-to-back absolutely yeah yeah okay
that was still the plan until this
fungal happened and I spoke to Andrew
our executive producer and again I could
hear it in his voice from the minute the
phone call started and my adrenaline
spiked I'm driving on the freeway and I
was like I need to pull over focus right
now and so I pulled over and he he let
me know that they they love me I'm very
much a part of the family of Dancing
with the Stars but they couldn't partner
me up with a partner this season and
would you say when he said that I
honestly was in shell shock I was still
trying to process it was a real am I
dreaming
moment because it was such a shock to me
there was no hint that this would be the
case and there never is by the way we
all go through the same thing every
season we don't know if we're back until
we get that pickup letter and I've been
sitting pretty comfortable for a while
and you know maybe a fan favorite I mean
truly a fan favorite I thank you and we
have incredible fans I think we have a
lot of fan favorites on the Charlatans
and it's still a beautiful wonderful
cast but it was a it was a very
surprising phone call for me but at the
same time I got off that phone call and
I was very sad and I had to process take
a few minutes get back on the freeway
and go to this meeting and I walked into
this meeting with someone I'm actually
developing another show concept with and
then who
also said also I have two other shows
that I want to talk to you about and I
was like okay universe I hear you there
are some other things that I need to try
right now you're opening up space for me
to do this I wouldn't have had these
opportunities had I have not had the
last eight and a half years with this
beautiful show Dancing with the Stars
right okay I'm ready I've been
challenged I've the universe said put
your money where your mouth is now let's
go do the things you talked about so
okay yeah did they ever give you any
sort of reason honestly not not beyond
we couldn't partner you up this season
and what's tough about hearing that is
bow dance with everyone from Andy Dick
to Bobby burns to a Backstreet Boy there
is no type right
so and it has nothing to do with height
and it has nothing to do with anything
so for whatever reason the the people in
the room that decide who's on the cast
felt that I wasn't what they wanted for
this version of the show and that's okay
right because the team in there has
changed not everybody can love you not
everybody's gonna vibe with you maybe
they don't want a redhead this season
you know there's three blondes and three
brunettes I think maybe I stick out like
a sore thumb and they don't want that or
maybe it's that my choreography they
kind of got bored with who knows and it
doesn't matter it really doesn't matter
because at the end I'm never gonna know
the real reason behind it and it's to be
honest irrelevant it's happened I'm here
I've been given an opportunity of 12
months of other adventures yeah and who
knows what's gonna happen next year
whether they want me back or they don't
or is this the end I have honestly no
idea that's their call have you talked
to them about possibly coming back for
next season do you have a bad taste in
your mouth after all of this I
definitely don't have a bad taste but I
am sad I am sad that if hypothetically
this was my last season with Bobby wow
what a wonderful way to go out and
having one with him and and their friend
that I made in him too but not having
the opportunity to know that it was my
last season or after so long going on my
own terms and being able to go around to
all of our crew members and all of our
camera guys and everybody in wardrobe
everyone who the last eight and a half
years has been my family has wrangled me
when needed to has helped
understand learn over these years and
together we've created this beautiful
show I have so much gratitude for every
single person with even the follow spot
up in the rafters you know they they
help you see my face you know without
everybody in that room we don't get to
make that show and so I would have loved
that chance to know and you know when
you just savor every moment if you know
that it's gonna be the last of it
that I wish I had a little bit and I
think you deserve that and I think
people are mostly shocked because you
are the reigning chant like none is wild
I'm not gonna that is wild but yeah I
don't have any answer for that but what
a Bobby say cuz Bobby told us that he
called the show to make sure it wasn't
his fault and I know he always gives
good advice he's a good guy what have
you guys talked about he's an amazing
guy honestly it's he pretty typical them
when we when we briefly spoke it was
like honestly I was at a bit of a loss I
don't know I'm hearing these things I'm
hearing those things but that's also
what I was just seeing on social media
you know and there's still a train of
people that are wild about the fact that
Bobby and I won and that we broke the
show and we're the reason that there's
no spring season which is true people
love Bobby bones and people love you and
you he had an incredible journey because
of yeah you I mean because of us you
know and my storytelling with him and
and what we did and it was a great
season but also what I know from
chatting with Bobby is they used his win
to recruit three of the celebrities
Lauren Alaina and there was two others
too now show you don't have to be a
dancer to be on this show okay that
really was stopping I think a lot of
celebrities from wanting to do it
because if you're not a gymnast you're
not an athlete you don't have dance
ability why bother doing and everything
exactly so I think it's a beautiful
thing that that was able to happen and
no I don't think it's above it you know
I wanted the reason I'm not back that
would be ridiculous yeah but who knows
again at the end of the day I've I think
even no answer other than they just
couldn't pay me up this season very
interesting it is interesting I was told
that Kim Johnson won it and then she
wasn't brought back and then she came
back and she wanted again which I was
going to ask you if this is the first
time that
somebody hasn't been asked back after
winning that I don't know I know there
are people that have done it by choice
okay
I don't know if there was ever anyone
that wasn't asked back after winning who
knows I've been texts some of my
producers and I was like am i difficult
like what is it is it is there something
that I've done wrong here in the my
first 24 hours of trying to process this
and they were all like we love you
you're so good at giving story you're so
easy to work with you know how to
deliver or anything that we need and you
bring out the best in your partner so
absolutely not not when I was back there
for so you think just last week with
Artem and of course some of our crew is
putting together the the beautiful new
set that I can't wait to see actually
that I would pass them in the halls and
we'd stop and have a hug and everyone
express their sadness that I wasn't
there but just because I'm not there for
the season I'm not competing doesn't
mean that these guys are any less than
my family I will absolutely go I will
absolutely support
I can't wait to cheer them on in the
audience and you know who leaves it up
for them and just be proud of what
they're doing because regardless of
being asked back or not by people in
production that have an idea of what
they want for the show doesn't take away
that these people have spent so much
time with on my family and I have a lot
of love for them so yeah I can't not be
there for them of yours so you say
you're gonna be in the ballroom are
gonna be there premiere night I want to
I'm hoping to there is a something else
that I may have to do if I can get out
in time I will if it's not the premiere
because I know Bobby's going and I want
to be exactly yes but if I can't do that
then it will be the following week so
you're gonna be watching this season two
absolutely takes a strong person because
we did we talked to our demand he said
it's gonna be too hard to watch just
because of all the emotions and the
frustration and maybe that'll change for
him as the season progresses no one's
saying it's not gonna be hard you know
even walking into CBS Studios or driving
into the light there is there is a loss
there because it's been a part of my
life for so long but I can't be selfish
about that and I can't wallow in that I
can only look at what this shows given
me for the last eight and a half years
it's given me a life I could never have
imagined it's opening up doors for me
now that I could probably never have
even dreamt about walking through if
hadn't have been a part of this and so I
can only say thank you and go with
gratitude whether this is the end or not
who knows and give some love back to it
as well at the same time you know
through the people and through
supporting for it there is no animosity
for me there's no shade there's
definitely sadness yes but that's normal
that's gonna happen I'd be lying if I
said I wasn't sad be terrible if I
wasn't sad actually
of course and I'm sad I don't get to
give the transformative power of dance
to a person for that journey and create
all the things but there are other ways
to create all the things there are and
you're doing all of them yeah I do want
to ask about your lunch with Tom my time
what did he say to you he was we had a
great catch up and he asked me even he's
like do you know why there's a reason I
was like honestly I've been given no
reason there's nothing that I can tell
you there's I've asked people no one can
give me an answer and we were just very
very sad and we had a little chat about
some of the controversy he got caught up
in a little bit there and well the shot
space yeah a little bit happier and so
you're not paired with Shawn I would
struggle
I would probably struggle especially
regardless of whether you are or are not
a supporter of Shawn right whoever is
dancing with him is going to I mean I
would be terrified to open my social
media because people are either for you
were against you and she's going to
unfortunately be in that world and
she'll post a photo of him and some
people are gonna love it and some people
are gonna hate it more so than any other
partner on the show and I think that
whoever his partner is has a very very
big job ahead of them and is gonna need
to be able to separate themselves from
other people's opinion off this guy I
would really struggle with that that
would be very really tough do you know
who his partner is I do you do right
she's struggling a little bit she's not
struggling at all I think I first I
think
all six of our girls could have you know
handled it beautifully but she's
definitely the right pick for him in the
sense that she's she's capable she's
talented she's level-headed so we're all
about girls though I'm talking about all
of them at this point and I think that
you know if anyone can she can basically
I know you're very close to all the
girls who has been the biggest support
since all of this has happened
the three goals that I've spoken to the
most would be obviously Peter and
Lindsey and Emma with connected quite a
bit and as soon as everything went down
I mean a lot of people text me but those
three were the ones that were just like
absolutely heartbroken couldn't believe
it no hesitation in or gosh what do I
say and how do I approach it it was just
like word vomit if I miss you and I
can't believe this is happening and that
was really special but then there's also
it's a situation where some people don't
know how to approach it because it's
like they're on and you're not and they
probably feel bad about that and it's
like how do I say the right things but
everyone was so supportive and you know
and honest and that speaks to your
guys's beautiful friendship that you've
had on this show for however many
seasons everyone is yeah has been on
yeah yeah it's nice to hear that you're
gonna be watching and you're gonna be
cheering them on I will any chance that
they'll be like a cameo from you maybe
has that been talked about I mean listen
I'm down you know if we do it do a
Disney week which they probably aren't
because I've heard they're doing no
themes but I'll just be Ariel on a rock
in the background like Where's Waldo
spot the redhead you were such a great
aerial Oh finally got to do it it was so
good it was so epic I would love to and
I certainly wouldn't say no to it either
and if it lines up that they want me to
and I can I would love to go into a
little performance for them more
choreographing a big number I'm down to
do all the things but it's boy who knows
if they'll ask again that's that's their
choice yeah but I have actually been
approached by a couple of different
shows full choreography well you just
did so you think you can dance with
Artem mm-hmm and there's two more shows
one was actually yesterday which is a
favorite show of mine I can't say it
until I'm confirmed like I don't a sec I
don't want to put it out there until is
it a show you've done before no it's not
even a dance show it's it's a drama TV
series and you're gonna guess star no
Cara you're gonna choreograph okay we
work on the guests yeah yeah that would
be amazing
yeah you and this is us yeah I would
definitely be in
as many auditions as I possibly can be
there's a couple of different scripts of
potential movies that have been sent to
me but it's all all of these are maybes
and all of them could fall through or
they could all work who knows
that's exciting part you know that's the
thing about this industry too that I
think people don't always understand is
that it's a roller coaster that's right
it is looking back at what you have done
with dancing how do you feel about that
journey oh my gosh it's been epic yeah
like I struggle to find another word for
it it's the last eight and a half years
I've grown into not just a different a
better version of myself but my craft
and my art and discovering truly I think
this is where I understood the
transformative power of dance because it
always did it for me but being able to
see that happen for other people for
Noah Galloway for James Hinchcliffe for
Nick Carter for there were so many
people that went on a journey and
discovered things deep inside themselves
and worked through them Bobby burns as
well it's been such a special thing for
me to be able to give that to other
people and to be able to create some
honestly some of my favorite pieces on
the show like the the things that I did
with Noah the ones that people I think
talked to me about the most when they
see me I was just traveling back today
from sorry yesterday from Portland and I
got stopped in the airport by people
saying Noah Galloway that stuff you did
with the soldier and and how that
impacted people's lives so right down to
and it's the simple things right down to
the big freestyle but also the moment
that gets brought up for me the most is
a Viennese Waltz when we walked up the
stairs the same way because of you know
the way that he would have to swing he's
like and I matched him and I thought
something so simple can inspire someone
and impact them and make them feel
something and wow I got to do that for
eight and a half years you created that
moment yes you did that isn't that what
you will miss most absolutely yeah
absolutely I will miss beyond missing my
peas and and everybody around me and us
being in that space together I will miss
that journey of getting to know the soul
inside the human in front of me how they
work what they need what they need me to
be
what kind of coach they need me to be
and how I can take parts of their story
and turn
into something inspirational for other
people to listen to watch yeah I will
get to create all the things whether it
is my own show or this or that or
someone else's choreo whatever it is but
it won't ever be that experience that
only ever lives on Dancing with the
Stars
and I am again it's only grateful I got
to do it for eight and a half years my
soul could do it for another eight and a
half you know you never get over that
yeah it's such a beautiful gift
especially when you're an artist and a
creator to be able to do things that
have so much truth to them and actually
have an impact on people is just well
that's why we love that show because of
that what do you make of all the changes
there are a lot of changes well I'm
excited about seeing the ballroom I'm
definitely I've heard it's beautiful or
some of the dancers have said it is
absolutely stunning that really makes me
excited it was time to change up the
vibe in there we've had very much the
same vibe for a while my box and yeah
and so whatever it is I cannot wait to
discover that what are all the changes
that you know like I know there's no
seams yeah I know that they've got rid
of the themes I think it's a different
band Oh like different musical direction
that we're going in that's interesting I
love that band
yeah so there's there's a changes are
they yeah there's not there's no troupe
yeah I'll be like those dances of some
sort I think having no troupe is a real
shame but I also understand where people
were coming from that kind of every
dance is looking like a freestyle that's
for real like look how big I had to go
buggies freestyle to make it look like a
freestyle because I had every man and
his dog in our number every week right
because it's just what we needed
yes but I understand that sometimes that
needs to be stripped back so you can
just focus on them learning this cha-cha
and the dance and and not have so much
going on around it so I do respect that
and I think that is exciting because now
our viewers their viewers will see the
show so we're to get used to their I
will see the show build and build and
build instead of just being shy big all
the ones and that's important sure I
think not having a most memorable year
theme I mean obviously I'm gonna say
that's a terrible mistake because it's
my favorite yeah but you know maybe it
was just a little too much for
some people they thought it was a little
too softly a little too sad who knows
come on it's Dancing with the Stars
people worried with the fire people and
honestly that's all I really know of it
to be honest I know directions on
costumes has changed a little bit I know
a lot of things in the production office
that have changed but I don't know what
effect that will have on camera for the
live shows right that's just sort of the
workings behind it you were a judge on
Dancing with the Stars Australia do you
feel like maybe this decision was made
because they have an intention of making
you a judge perhaps next season do you
judge here yeah I don't know I'll take
it back yes I mean let's put that into
universe let's be the universe I'm gonna
be a judge on season 29 of days with
ourselves I did not get that vibe okay
but I certainly would love to be a part
of that panel and that team I mean for
me what I loved so much about judging in
Australia was after all these years of
during the show and all of the knowledge
that I have of ballroom dancing I was a
tendon stamp Ian went to the World
Championships for it you know I got to
give back in a completely different way
I got to see these new pros in Australia
that are so unbelievably talented that
haven't learned all the little tricks of
the trade
right we've learned on how to fix things
and what you need to focus on where to
prioritize your teaching and so I got to
nurture and inspire in a completely
different way and at the end of the day
I'm also a technician so I can be tough
and as any of my partner's I'm a tough
coach so I demand a high standard but I
also have empathy for everything that
you've gone through in the week and I
never wanted to be that judge that had
them stand in front of me at the end of
a dance they're exhausted maybe it was
awful but they're exhausted and they
just probably put 45 hours of their week
into this no one wants to feel like
they've had no validation for that no
one wants to feel like it was for
absolutely nothing I wanted to let them
know I appreciated what they did then I
could see what they tried to do but this
was where I needed to go I loved judging
I could judge if I would judge more than
just a dancer I like any talent so I
just I love seeing people get out there
and express yeah well we've seen Julie
and become yeah as well yeah so is that
something that you maybe have your eyes
on absolutely yeah I mean don't I see
takers Jules is phenomenal and I like it
yes absolutely I feel so at home I mean
obviously I can talk for days I don't I
don't ever shut up but I love I love I
love that and I love creativity and I
love performance I love live television
and if I can be a part of it in that
capacity that would to me would feel
like an epic next step yeah of course I
do I know you said that they didn't
really give you a reason just that they
didn't have a partner I do have a theory
okay I think maybe you are becoming too
big you have too many fans ah what do
you think of this theory I think you
just struck my ego and that felt
wonderful I think well then I challenge
that with saying what about Val okay you
know what I mean I think Val equally has
his fan base and is a no name on the
show and also any of them really but Val
and I think have been around the longest
out other than Sharon Chelle and also I
challenge you that was Cheryl so whilst
that feels really good to me right and
right about here and strokes my ego and
makes me want to smile
I think wonderful but probably not okay
and then we don't think it's budget
either can't be budget I wasn't I was on
par with people definitely not the the
most expensive and certainly not by an
amount that would break the show if they
kept me yeah okay I know what I mean I
want to go back to working with our
tongue okay because the choreography I
watched the routine it was so beautiful
good how was it working with him in that
different capacity it was actually great
to work with him so I doubt for 10 days
Wednesday Burning Man had absolutely no
reception was Kundalini Yoga ring it up
at 6 o'clock in the morning and not
paying attention to anything where when
I left the plier and I saw autumns
interview it really broke my heart how
brokenhearted he was and I knew he was
sad were being there for each other but
he wasn't he was struggling with the
healing process and the processing of it
but when we got to work with each other
for so you thinking dance he was
definitely bit more peponi stabbed ready
and recharged to do do and create and
into other things and he myself and
another person actually building a show
concept to pitch a live show which I'm
again I can't say come on no but it's a
very new concept about its you end Artem
both yeah I've Adam and I are putting it
together to both be in it but also
produce it we're working with a great
team right now I'm putting it together
and it's super super exciting yeah it's
just something different and wild and
creative and dance related dance related
dancing acting related it's a show a
live show but that should be really fun
and creating with him for so you think
you know yet I mean Adam and I have
always danced very well together there
is there are people that just move with
an energy that you connect to and
Artemis one of them he can take up frame
with me and I don't even need to know
the steps he can lead me around that
floor into anything honestly that's how
half of our dancers on tour came
together summertime and lovey on Rose
was just him doing things and then you
know just following working together
keep that change that we do yeah we have
a really wonderful friendship a great
creativity together and we really
balance each other out in a creative
space he's he's so like smooth and suave
and like the when guys learned from him
they're like I just like he's sexy Jesus
I just want to be like you know what I
mean and then I'm in I'm in a little bit
more of a drill sergeant and I keep it
going but I've got the energy and you
know we we make a great team yeah and I
love that and so you think was really
happy with us and hopefully they'll have
us back next season I was gonna say
could there be a place on that judging
panel I'm so you think they did just get
Laurieann who I think is is wonderful
and they do have their panel and they
have Mary who is the board expert yeah
but again I would love that yeah you
know being a part of a show like that
that show gives you the tingles yes
sitting in the audience and watching
these kids just dance for their life is
really something special
how was Artem he's doing good yeah he's
looking so happy and in love right now
look at him you like him a Nicki
together love obsessed with this again
yeah I just I am so happy that they
found their way to each other and seeing
the love between them and how just
beautiful and genuine and and open they
are about it I think he's a really nice
thing for Adam to he's not necessarily
been the most open person on social
media
really bringing other things out of him
and he's sharing himself more with
everyone which is really important if
you want to be in this world yes you
know she's bringing things out of him
that I think weren't there before and
she's certainly his greatest champion
right now and supporting him through
those hard times and I think she's
probably a big key part in what has got
him through it and I love how outspoken
she's been me too yeah and I think she's
always very much been that person and
that woman and I love that about her so
much and I think it's probably showing
him that he can have that too and that's
why even though his interview was
definitely heartbroken I was actually
really proud of him I was really proud
of him for being able to say those
things and be okay with it coming from
someone that doesn't say a bad word
about anybody but - honestly speak about
his heartbreak and the truth of how it
went down he spoke his mind he spoke his
mind yeah no one can be in trouble for
that you can only be respected for that
in my opinion so I was really proud of
him and I think he's doing great I think
he's gonna be just fine yeah he did say
he thinks that contracts for the dancers
should be different so that you aren't
finding out you're not on the show a few
days beforehand do you feel the same
there is actually a clause in our
contract that gives them a deadline date
of when they have to let us know by and
I think it did get passed also they
violated I think it to go and I don't
want to drunk or tan it necessarily I
can't remember the official date whether
it was from the first performance date
or the first rehearsal date I don't know
okay so they might have still been in
the clear because essentially from the
first performance date it was still like
three weeks okay but yes I do agree I do
agree with that because regardless of
Adam and I season 2 season everybody on
that show has no idea if they have a job
until they get the pickup letter and
pair that with the exclusivity that's in
the contract it makes it very very
difficult for you to work if you are not
bought back and if you haven't lined
things up and right now pretty much
everything's already booked for the end
of the year because it's already been
done and you know what you can book
things long-term but finding things
short-term it becomes a little bit more
difficult and I'm so grateful for what's
becoming to me but I do agree with that
that is a very tough contract for for
people that have mortgages and baby
and lives to exist with and it would be
fair if they were to let the dancers
know months ahead of time so that you
could go and pursue other jobs and
opportunities and I mean they do that on
the English one they know months ahead
of time because they're also prepping
things but their season airs around the
same time as us but they know back in
June I think it is whether they're back
or not and they are only year-to-year
contracts but they know months ahead of
time if they are going to be back and
that I think is a much more respectful
way of doing it absolutely before we
wrap up do you have a message to your
fans oh oh oh get emotionally supportive
you and they love you so much hi they're
gonna get emotional saying these things
thank you so much for all of the love
and the support and in the words of how
much you miss me and you're defending me
like my champions with her if you feel
it's unjust but what I I do want to say
to you is that it is all love and it's
all gratitude and we got a beautiful
eight and a half years of me being on
this incredible show and getting to
create and no one has ever said that
it's the end and whether it is that I
come back and do another season or not
I'm always gonna be putting things out
there for you guys I love and appreciate
you all so much you're in my heart I
have a vested interest in you all and
I'm trying to create things to for you
and to help affect change in this world
especially for women and that's all
that's all things that are coming but it
was all inspired by you guys and thank
you and even though it hurts and I'm sad
to be gone and it's a sole point feeling
the love and the energy from all of you
certainly does does help and does make
it feel better so thank you thank you
thank you and I love you
[Music]